foreign
named Rich who wrote into us and I
wanted to be respectful and I wanted to
accept his feedback and his criticism
here during our sucky ads segment Rich
says
hello and thank you for the podcast I've
listened for a few months now and some
of the content really hits home which I
love unfortunately
this positive is heavily weighed down by
a negative
in every episode you say
advertisements suck and while I
understand your position hearing this
makes me have an uneasy feeling in my
stomach why well I grew up poor and
chose advertising as a career it put
food on my table and a roof over our
heads
it's kept my kids from growing up the
way I did having to move out in the
middle of the night skipping rent before
getting evicted it's provided many great
experiences and opportunities for my
kids
I can keep going but you get the point
all that said while I appreciate your
opinion advertising does not suck
it's truly been a blessing
and if you continue to say this
I will have to stop listening thank you
for taking the time to read this Rich
hmm well Rich first off you're gonna
have to stop listening and that's okay
and here's my response to Rich I just
want to read this real quick and I'd
love to hear your comments about it I
said hi Rich
I totally understand
if it helps advertisements suck it's not
a moral stance or a judgment
advertisements suck is merely a
preference we the minimalists personally
dislike advertisements and we don't want
to clutter our podcast with them
I imagine if you repeatedly said kale
sucks on your podcast and I worked in
the kale industry I would be turned off
by that too
perhaps TK Ryan and I can answer your
specific question on episode 376 during
the next recording session so that's
what we're doing right now in the
meantime we answered a similar question
our previous episode episode 375 so
without reprising that entire
conversation you all can go back to that
I don't say Rich totally understand if
you stop listening wishing you the best
we do think advertisements suck and it
is not our moral stance it's not oh my
God you shouldn't be doing this rich
we simply dislike it yeah and it's okay
to dislike something
yeah you know advert advertisers
um
they
take advantage of of people poor people
um poor people being some of those
people that take advantage of but and
not every Advertiser does that of course
yeah so yeah it's interesting I mean you
know advertisements do suck but yes I
love how you said it's not a moral
judgment it's not a moral judgment it's
just the fact that I kind of look at
this as an experiment can we do a
podcast can we do everything that we do
without ever taking a dollar uh one
dollar from from advertising and so far
it's worked great you know
um but yeah it's uh it's it's uh yeah
Rich it's not a moral judgment just
please if you get anything out of this
just know that we're not judging you
morally it's just something that we
don't want to participate in
since I am on a mission to help equip as
many people as I can with the conceptual
tools that help them create wealth as
wealth is defined by them I want to
begin by giving a shout out to Rich
in creating wealth for your family
overcoming the poverty that characterize
your youth uh developing the skills that
you could take out into the marketplace
and solve problems for other people then
turning around and being able to create
a lifestyle for your children and your
family that you could only dream of as a
child props to you I hope more and more
people can be able to follow your
footsteps and do that you sound like
somebody that would make a great mentor
to a lot of the types of students that I
teach and I work with so I love that
more than anything else uh the second
thing I would say too is you know
um sometimes I do wonder if
certain terms or words or Manner and
modes of expression are are just never
going to work so for instance as we have
talked about many times we don't have to
get into the Weeds about it now
um there is a technical sense in which I
would consider myself to be a supporter
of capitalism but what I mean by that
consumer Choice customer accountability
freedom of competition almost no critic
of critic of capitalism means that they
mean something like corporate greed
um you know bureaucracy getting in bed
with big business and all these other
sorts of things that I also criticize
and so whenever I have conversations
about free markets and economics
I give up on that word capitalism I
don't try to bend people to my
understanding of the term I just say
forget it you can Define that label
however you want I don't even want to
use it let's talk about the ideas and
sometimes I do want to that with
advertising because I know what is meant
here that we're not going to exchange
our freedom you know in order to take a
paycheck from an Advertiser but I don't
look at my TV and see a Tropicana
commercial or I don't look at a Nike ad
and think you guys are immoral for that
you guys are wrong for that and you know
if Nike came to me and said hey can you
do a commercial where you put on your
shoes and if I like the shoe maybe maybe
Nike's not the right fit for me but I
don't think advertising in that sense is
wrong and I don't think that what Rich
does sucks I don't think Rich's career
sucks but there's a very particular
understanding that we have when we say
that and sometimes I do I do question
whether or not it's possible to
communicate that in a nuanced way that
actually works I think there's some room
to
question the attachment to the language
here but rich I understand where you're
coming from man I totally do and I
understand exactly what is meant here in
in the use of that phrase yeah I I hope
we can have your support but at the end
of the day what I support more than
anything else is each individual doing
what's best for them so I wish you
nothing beloved and I hope you continue
to create more wealth and Inspire other
people to do the same I hate to lose you
know much love did you enjoy this
Standalone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free